all right in the lobby of financial
peace Plaza Jason and Stephanie are with
us hey guys how are you hey Dave how you
doing where you guys from El Segundo
California then what's that near Elliot
very cool good to have you guys thank
you so much shirt what's it say I can't
see the bottom
says Dave is my homeboy get a picture
together at the break I like that yeah
that's fine
so you're here to do a debt free scream
how much have you paid off
two hundred and thirty four thousand
dollars Wow
fifty months in how long fifty months
fifty months making what kind of money
150 to 200 yeah what do you guys do for
a living well I own an elite private
training gym the actual the best one in
the world it's called a strata fitness
awesome little shout out there and the
website is just trying to fitness doc
there we go all right there we go so
you're doing well congratulations very
cool now what kind of debt was the two
hundred thirty four thousand it was a
combination of credit-card school loans
medical bills cars Wow
that's it so fifty months ago four years
ago basically 50 months ago happened
that made you guys say okay we're
changing everything well we met we met
and I had no idea that Stephanie's
mother had given her the book and my
father are giving me the book and when
we met yeah we didn't even realize that
we both are actually reading the book at
the same time and we just went from
there and I was fortunate enough I
actually got a settlement from my last
employer before I opened up my own
business and it was pretty huge and I
was like eh guess what I'm gonna do and
she's like pay off your car and I'm like
yep exactly and so paid off my car with
a huge chunk and that just gave us gave
us momentum to push on I love it I love
it
so which one of those debts that when
you paid it off you went
I am so glad you people are gone you're
stupid I hate you
definitely the school loans though like
oh my god Sallie Mae how much Sallie Mae
was there over 100 Wow Wow very cool
yeah hey man
two hundred thirty-four thousand that's
some high-stepping right there that's
pretty impressive in 50 months you got
it here's the thing it's not only a lot
of money it's not only a long time but
you kept with it yeah we kept with it
with just our faith in God and we
religiously actually listened to you and
that's when we really decided to to get
ghazal intent so we were listening to
your show and we heard people you know
giving their testimonies and their
stories and we were like and you know
what this is like motivating you know we
can just keep attacking it and then next
thing you know we went from just
throwing you know a few grand added at a
time to like alright we're gonna throw
10 grand this month and then we were
setting goals we're like all right this
month we're gonna throw 13,000 edit this
month and we we just had no idea how how
how real the the debt snowball was and
it was truly like a snowball effect you
know it just kept getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and we were able to
you know do it with the grace of God and
and during the time we started a
business we got married and we had our
first son Elijah
you know how old is Elijah eight so
that's the coolest part cuz we still had
our life you know we still were able to
do the big things pay for our wedding
cash but still get rid of our debt
mm-hmm you know very neat very neat well
you pulled it off so what kind of
correlation do you see between what you
did with the money and what you teach in
the gym with Fitness man that's a good
question but I mean I really I really
like to tell teach my clients on how to
really focus on making a plan and
sticking to it and that's you can't do
anything without a plan or a vision so
that's the biggest thing and Steph and I
sat down and we literally wrote out our
goals and we stuck to them we held
ourselves accountable and that's the
same thing I do with my clients to get
them in the best shape of their life
I love it if you look deeply in your
radio you will see Jason striking a pose
so what do you tell people when they
find out you paid off two hundred
thirty-four thousand dollars and debt
and they say how did you do that what do
you tell them the secrets are as nice
eke rich but what do you tell them the
principles are for getting out of debt I
think just well just sticking to the
plan and not really caring what other
people think you just have to just do
what's right for you and what's right
for you you're alive in it funny how
many people have an opinion about your
money yes Ryan we came all the way down
from LA just to say thank you personally
because if it wasn't for you we wouldn't
be able to even do it we wouldn't have
the inspiration to do it and we both you
know are Christians and we know the Word
of God and it just it's just a pleasure
to have someone who is speaking the
ministry every day and we appreciate you
for allowing God to work through you to
help us and the millions of people
around the United States as well well
thank you what do you guys return search
in LA we go to the rock in San Diego
when we're when we're down there that's
that's the church that she joined and
then our church together that we visit
them here in LA and in Los Angeles is
called faith inspirational and confident
cool very cool
yeah good hey guys thank you for making
a trip all the way out here we're
honored and beautiful baby he's awesome
he's been ranting and happy look at it
me seven life is good he's a ham we
changed his family tree family tree you
really get two hundred thirty four
thousand dollars paid off fifty months
making one hundred and fifty to two
hundred thousand Jason and Stephanie and
Elijah count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one we're dead
free
yeah that's how it's done
bad that's fun
Oh